Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
He is Rob and we are back with Batman ghost stories and we get the origin
of ghost maker. Now I say this origin loosely,
not because we don't get a full origin, we do,
but I feel like this might be expanded on later on by James Tinian.
So kind of keep your eyes out for the idea that we might get more of an
expansion here. Um,
another thing that we're doing here is I'm going to give away a Rob core ring on
the discord server.
So make sure you guys check out the discourse server down in the description.
Um,
I'm going to give one away on Friday at 6:00 PM Eastern time when I do my weekly
Q and a. So make sure you guys check that out. Uh,
and then I'm also going to list rubber core rings for sale again, uh,
once we get around to, uh, really close to Christmas time, right?
So maybe here in about a week or so, uh,
I'm going to list them for sale that way you guys can buy them and then you guys
can get them in time for Christmas. So that's going to be cool.
That's going to be fun. I also will have size 12 rings.
So those are the guys who need size twelves.
We actually have those in stock now, or they just recently came in. So yes. Uh,
so having said that, um, we are, we're covering this origin right now.
This whole thing comes in the aftermath of the last video.
The last story that we did were Batman alongside lb killer and Holly Quinn were
all basically captured by ghost maker. They were all defeated by ghost maker.
So at this point they're all basically stuck in Arkham asylum.
And it's one of these funny things where Batman basically wakes up before
everybody else. But that's because of the fact that he's Batman,
that's not true. It's because of the fact that ghost maker, uh,
didn't give him as much of a, or didn't give him as strong of a shot of the, uh,
of the, basically the thing that knocked him out of the anesthetic, uh,
as he did with Harley Quinn and encounter killer, right?
Because he wanted a Batman to wake up early because he wanted to have this
conversation directly with him.
And the whole idea is we don't really find out the full depth of this
conversation instead.
It's really him just kind of talking to Batman and saying that with everything
going on, that, that this, this clown killer kid is basically just,
or at least count Hunter, I guess his official name, uh,
is basically just the latest symptom of this disease, right?
That Batman has essentially failed as a superhero in almost every way, right?
That Gotham is not better because of Batman. Gotham is actually worse.
And so what we ended up doing here before we get this kind of full on
explanation is we switch over to Barbara Gordon, right?
We switched over to bat girl, who's basically talking to Dick Grayson, right?
While you know, a crime's kind of happening,
some criminals are robbing a bank and Dick Grayson's beating them up and talking
to her at the same time, which makes sense, right? Because you know,
Dick Grayson, he can do almost anything.
And so what we.
Ended up finding out is that in the time with Madonna and having been missing
for the last six hours and the time that ghost maker's been in the city of
Gotham, uh, the professor pig was found back at Arkham asylum.
Despite the fact that he was on, he was on the loose,
the Yakuza triads and the whisper gang have all just abandoned the city
completely, right?
That six people were found dead at the iceberg lounge of the penguin and the
penguin himself is believed to be underground.
And one of his bunkers that effectively the criminal element in Gotham has just
vanished, tried just seemingly disappeared overnight.
These guys just took off and that's what night week kind of times in,
I can't believe that ghost maker actually came to Gotham.
And it gives us this idea that Dick Grayson knows who the ghosts maker is and is
something that he's actually known for quite some time,
because that's what Barbara Gordon has. Some she's like,
how do you know who the ghost maker is? And he's like, well,
I've known about him for a long time, right? But I've only ever seen him once.
And what he does is he recalls this story from back when he was younger,
right back when he, around the time that he first became Robin.
And he talks about how him and Batman had basically been chasing some guy,
right?
Some low-level guy there was making a break and fleeing the United States and
Batman and them had basically tracked him down to this location.
And once they got to an airport where this guy was going to be taking off that
then suddenly they were met by the arrival of a,
of ghost maker who had already essentially captured this villain.
And as soon as they get out and as soon as Batman sees its ghost maker,
that man gets back in the backswing and then tells Robin we're going back to
Gothic. And when Robin's like, why? Like, like who is this guy? Like,
why are we just going to go back to go back to Gotham?
Batman kind of starts talking about when he was younger and when he started
undergoing this whole, this whole process of becoming Batman, right? Yeah.
If you guys, any of you guys recall,
this was especially important during Batman year one by Frank Miller,
which really covered all that stuff. It's one of the reasons why, uh,
freight Miller's Batman work is kind of considered to be some of the Seminole
Batman work that exists out there because it did so much retelling of his
origin.
And a lot of those things that have kind of been changed or removed over the
years are in a lot of ways, ignored by fans.
And it's kind of considered to be like the definitive story like Batman year one
is largely believed to be the definitive Batman story.
That man year zero from the new 52, a lot of fans kind of, uh,
basically marry that with that man year one,
and then just kind of combine them together for a singular story, right?
And say, this is how Bruce Wayne became Batman.
This is how it all sort of sort of came together.
But the long and short of this is that when Bruce Wayne starts talking about his
life, when he was younger,
than he traveled around the world to all these different places, right.
Then when his parents died,
he made a promise to himself made this oath that he would basically live a war
against criminals.
And he wanted to become the kind of person that could fulfill that oath.
And so we went from place to place training with all different kinds of people,
right. He trained with autonomous father. He trained with wild cat,
I think is what a name, his name is.
I don't know if he trained with all these different people, but along the way,
he met this young guy and this young guy that he met really kind of proved to be
somebody whose ego was just ridiculously unbearable,
but it was a person who thought very much the same way Bruce Wayne did that.
It wasn't just enough to become skilled in like a singular martial art and
dedicate their life to that.
He wanted to become the absolute best crime fighter he could possibly be.
And what Bruce Wayne found here was a kind of comradery, right?
It was him and this guy working together and kind of presenting each other with
these almost unsolvable mysteries, these unsolvable problems,
basically how to make the world a better place,
dreaming about technology in the future, how crime can be solved,
different things like that.
And so when with Bruce Wayne kind of finding this friend,
this guy who was basically as, as egotistical as he was, was a very,
very strong competitor and was a very close friend of Bruce Wayne.
Bruce Wayne finally revealed his story saying that he's the son of Thomas and
Martha, that his parents were killed.
And the following that he basically wanted to kind of wage war against crime in
order to bring all that to an end. Right.
So nobody would have to go through what he went through.
The response to that was ghost got. He so mad.
And the reason why he tried to kill Bruce Wayne is that he told him he was weak.
That ghost maker was angry because he believed that he found somebody like him,
right? Somebody who was doing all of this, the art of it,
probably because it was just a thing that they desire to think that they pursued
to suddenly just better themselves and better the world around them.
That it wasn't some childish idea of vengeance. Now,
this is a really interesting concept. This is a really interesting thing.
A lot of times when you see characters like ghost maker presented and comic
books that have an origin story like this,
where they meet the main hero and the two of them become enemies.
Sometimes it's because of the fact that, especially in a situation like this,
that they were somehow less capable than the hero themselves.
And it's all just been an effort to prove that they're just as capable for ghost
maker. It's not that way. It's like, no,
I really want to make the world a better place.
I want to do this to make the world better.
You're doing it because you're mad that your mommy and daddy got shot.
And it's just, and that's basically what it is. Right. And that's,
what's so cool is because it moves ghost maker away from this guy.
Who's just like once upon a time, him and Bruce Wayne met each other,
Bruce Wayne got a black belt before him. And he's been over since,
instead of that, instead of something stupid and basic like that, it's no,
like you're just filled with vengeance, right?
Like you don't really have a desire to make the world better because you're
being altruistic.
You want to make the world better because your mommy and daddy got shot.
You're full of rage.
You want to make sure that nobody else has to go through that again. Golly, gee,
you're going to save the day. And in a lot of ways,
it kind of diminishes Batman. If I'm being honest with you guys,
I feel like it kind of diminishes him. Not necessarily in a terrible way, right.
Doesn't make us any less capable, but it really puts into perspective.
The goal of Batman, right?
He's just a little kid crying because his parents got shocked that it really is
all just based on vengeance and anger. He's in essence,
every ounce of a vigilante,
whereas ghost maker is being presented here from the words of Batman, as a guy,
who's doing all this because he genuinely and truly wants to make the world
better. And that totally changes the idea that he'll just kill villains, right?
It's not him killing them because it's easy. It is. I mean,
technically it is easy. So by default, that's a true statement,
but he does that because dead men can not be repeat offenders. Dead.
Men can not go back and commit crimes all over again.
Now I know it seems to take away from the human element,
but ghost maker also seems to kind of have this, this sort of threshold, right.
Where it's one thing to run criminals out of town. It's another to kill them.
And there's this kind of standard that he arbitrarily creates,
which is once they start committing acts of egregious enough,
didn't we kill them. And it seems to be the standard he created,
which is a reasonable one, is that if a villain basically becomes a killer,
then we kill him in turn. Right.
They sacrifice the right to life when they took somebody. Else's,
it's kind of interesting here, right? It's,
it's an interesting concept because from there,
like Robin kind of looks at that in any, he's listening to the story,
the Batman's telling him and he's like, well, you know, you're not weak, right?
I mean, like, I don't have to tell you that, but you know, that's not true.
And Batman is like, well, I don't feel weak. And that's when,
when Dick Grayson picks up on it, but you miss your friend. And Batman is like,
yes, I miss my friend. I miss the person that I spent so much time with now,
following that.
And when he continues kind of talking to Barbara Gordon about all this,
one of the things that he says is that when Batman jump-started Batman
incorporated, he reached out to, uh, to ghost maker. Now,
for those of you guys don't know what that is.
Batman incorporated was part of the grant Morrison run, right?
So grant Morrison's Batman run is considered by a lot of fans to be one of the
absolute best band, uh, best Batman runs and rightfully so.
It's amazing laser ridiculously good Batman series of Batman stories.
But the idea of the chronology is that during the events of final crisis,
Batman was shot by doomsday with, you know, his Omega sanction or whatever.
And technically it should've killed Batman because it would've killed anybody
else who was just a regular human,
but he was set back in time because he's too popular for DC to cancel.
And so that gave us a story, the return of Bruce Wayne,
during that time when Bruce Wayne was traveling through time that you had Dick
Grayson who became Batman and Damian Wayne became a new Robin.
And so you've got that series of stories, you know,
focusing on the Dick race in Batman era. And then of course,
once Bruce Wayne came back, his thought was okay,
we need to expand the bat family. Right.
And so that's when the bat family went international.
And so it was basically him traveling around to all these different places where
he found individuals who were effectively people fighting crime that seemed to
have like minds, right?
So that's where you end up getting like Lucius Fox's son, you know,
where you get, you have like a bat wing, I think is what he's called.
You have like a lot of those characters that kind of come into play.
Bruce Wayne, Brad,
a lot of these guys and then brought them into the bat family basically to kind
of make Batman a worldwide concept. Uh, when he reached out to ghost maker,
it apparently didn't go well, right now, this is James Tinian,
throwing in new information that didn't exist before, right?
Because ghost maker didn't exist until this story.
So he's just kind of adding this stuff. And, uh,
and then it turned into when Dick Grayson was working for spiral as the elder of
that terrible run,
where he was a spy that he basically ended up looking around for ghost maker and
that most of the intelligence community considers him to be an urban legend.
But there are a few classified reports that Dick Grayson had read that showed a
kind of run in between the great 10 in China and ghost maker himself.
And it was one of these things that if you knew where to look,
you could find evidence that ghost maker was real. Right.
But it's one of these things where he would basically show up into a city for
about a year or so,
he would eliminate all the crime and then he would leave before anybody ever
really even knew he was there or,
or without anybody ever even knowing he was ever there. Right. So like, it's,
he's just that wildly capable, you know? And so this guy is, you know,
very much lives up to his namesake. He's a ghost, right? This guy is a Phantom.
Now the funny thing about this, and as I was reading this, this screams,
the winter soldier from ed Rue bakers, captain America, right now,
it's not the first time we've ever seen anything like that. Right.
Ed Brewbaker was not the very first person to ever take a character or
previously died and then brought them back.
And somebody who had been used for espionage, right.
Eddie Baker was not the first person to ever do that. Right.
So before people show up to this, those DC who's stealing from Marvel, I guess.
I mean,
if you consider ed Brewbaker to be the only person who ever do that in the
history of literature, ah, fin. Sure. I guess, but that's not true. So, uh,
so it, it kind of, it reminded me of that in a lot of different ways. Right.
But the cool thing about this is you end up picking back up with Barbara Gordon
and you have Sandra Kane. Who's basically talking to her and saying, Hey, look,
you know, we don't, we're here. The side of this happened.
But the only evidence we have in terms of where they went is a plant on the wall
that basically spells Arkham. And that's how we know where he took him.
The poison Ivy plants what's left of poison. Ivy is basically just telling them,
like, go to Arkham right now. From there,
we switched back over to argument itself and you've got clown Hunter.
You've got Batman and Batman, of course already being awake.
When Harley Quinn wakes up a town, Hunter's like, Hey, like, okay,
what's going on here? Right. And of course, once she starts talking to him,
Kahn Hunter gets, right? It's on, you know, don't talk to me.
But Batman basically says, this is all a test, right?
This is a test by ghost maker to prove that you clown Hunter or every bit as bad
as he believes you are that if you give a criminal, the means to commit a crime,
that's what they will do because criminals are bad people and criminals commit
crimes that they cannot be redeemed. They cannot be fixed.
They cannot become better people that they just don't change.
Ghost maker is Gregory House from house MD. People don't change.
But you know, clown Hunter kind of seems to live up to this expectation.
Did he ends up discovering a couple of these sores, that clown, I'm sorry,
that ghost maker had left forum.
And then when Batman is like pleading with them, say, no, like, do not do this.
If you do this, you will prove ghost maker ripe.
The response to clown Hunter is I don't really care. Right?
She was there the night the jumper killed my parents.
And so even if it proves the point of ghost maker, I don't care.
I clown Hunter am going to kill Harley Clint. But with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob poor. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a like, and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible].